so I saw a video floating around on
Facebook that I think was originally
published last week and it was another
one of those Jimmy Kimmel dumb guy on
the street segments and yeah these
things get old after a while because
first of all we get it right I mean
there are a lot of idiots in America we
understand we get it you don't need to
keep proving it to us we're on board we
know yes it's kind of depressing so I'm
not really in the mood to laugh about it
anymore maybe the first few times we saw
it we started seeing these videos was
kind of funny now it's just it's not
funny anymore it's just really sad and
and that's all and also we know that
these are not exactly this is not
scientific research here because any
time you you see one of these segments
and the implication obviously is oh we
went down to the streets and we had this
really simple question we couldn't find
anyone who could answer it correctly
well no you definitely found some people
who could answer correctly but you
didn't put them in the video because
then it the tracks from the humor and it
detracts from the point you were trying
to make the point is that people are
stupid so we get so that that all of
course is true however
as
as cynical as I am and as jaded as I am
by these dumb guy interviews this one
still jumped out at me and was even more
depressing than usual in this video
maybe you've seen it
people were ad they were given a map of
the world without any of the countries
named on it and they were asked to just
point to one country on the map just one
and it could even be their own country
and they were able to find that Jimmy
kills producers were able to find
several presumably literate and
presumably educated adults who could not
point to one country on the map not even
their own country now they were they did
find several people who pointed to
Africa which of course is not a country
but they were not able to find or or
they were able to find a number of
adults who could not point to one single
country and that is
that truly is incredible because if you
can't point to one country map that
means that you have zero knowledge of
geography that isn't it that's one of
the most basic academic subjects and you
have zero knowledge of it none
I mean it's incredible and
it brings me back back to a point that I
I have made many times and I will now
make again
this is you know when you see these
videos the first thing that you think is
wow these people vote that's the really
scary and depressing thing is that these
people can't point to a country on the
map yet they go and vote and my point is
and I know this scene this seems very
scandalous and very upsetting to a lot
of Americans with their modern
sensibilities but I really believe that
we need to find some way to legally stop
these kinds of people from voting we
could see so many improvements in our
system in our culture in our society if
we could just stop eating the rain
mice's from voting
now if you're like the majority of
Americans then you probably labor under
the faulty assumption that everybody
should have the right to vote that this
is one of the most essential fundamental
rights and everyone should be able to do
it you may even think and I'm always
shocked when I encounter people like
this but there seems to be a popular
view that somehow America is improved
our society is improved by high voter
turnout and high voter participation
you always hear this in the media every
every every election season where but we
got to get the voting we got to get
voter turnout we got to get more people
involved more people voting doesn't
matter doesn't matter if they if they
have any knowledge that we just need to
get more people there we just need warm
bodies in the polls we just need people
voting they could be voting based on
absolutely nothing just we just need
them there this is this idea we have
that somehow it's a it is an objective
good to just have a bunch of people
voting even if half of them have no idea
where they are they're just wandering in
in some kind of half drunks stupor it's
just it's good it's good because its
participation in what other context
would we suggest that participation in
and of itself is like some kind of good
things as long as you're participating
it doesn't matter what the reason is
your of your participation doesn't
matter the quality of the participation
just participate it should be of
interest that our founding fathers that
would be the people who came up with our
system they never had this idea in mind
they never they never construct that the
best way to run the country is to just
have everybody voting they only gave the
vote to landowners and of course that
had the effect of automatically
disenfranchising black people and women
which is very bad thankfully over the
course of the life of the of the you
know the the next century and a half
voting has been opened up to to to those
groups and now we no longer discriminate
based on race or based on gender which
is great
but somewhere along the line we got it
into our silly little heads that
because we shouldn't discriminate based
on race and gender that means we
shouldn't discriminate based on anything
so we rightly did away with racial and
gender discrimination at the polls
we ran way too far in the other
direction and then we did away with all
forms of discrimination at the polls and
I think that's where we went wrong
we went way to the other end of the way
to the other extreme way too far
I think it's very clear
that voting should be a discriminating
process
and you absolutely should be subjected
to some forms of discrimination when you
go to vote in fact you're already
subjected to some forms of
discrimination at the polls that most
people agree should be there think about
age discrimination now there are some
people will want to lower the voting age
which I think it's a very stupid idea
but you rarely hear anyone say that we
should just get rid of the voting age
and anyone of any age should vote like
let's have 8 year-olds vote almost
everyone agrees that 8 year-olds should
not vote now why why do we all agree
that an 8 year old shouldn't vote what's
the reason for that well the reason is
that 8 year olds don't know anything and
they are not in any way whatsoever
contributing to society
they are entirely dependent on their
parents so let their parents vote but
not them so it's interesting we all
agree but for that reason that's the
reason that eight-year-old shouldn't
vote
but then we have to ask ourselves are
there in America a significant number of
people
who essentially have the maturity and
intelligence of eight-year-olds
and who are about as self-sufficient and
who contribute as much to society as
eight-year-olds and if those people
exist should we allow them to vote and
if we do allow them to vote on what
basis do we stop at year-olds from
voting where they're basically the same
now remember something
our politicians you'll never hear a
politician say what I'm saying right now
for obvious reasons be probably
political suicide but also politicians
for the most part especially the bad
politicians they really love it when a
lot of people vote they want to get
those numbers up they want to drive
people to the polls right why is that
because they know that the majority that
that that I should say informed
intelligent mature voters are in the
minority and those are the scary ones to
the politicians especially the bad
politics the bad politicians if you are
an informed mature intelligent voter the
bad politicians especially are afraid of
you and they hate you and they would
love it if they could stop you from
voting but they can't so instead their
plan is we're gonna take your vote and
we're gonna drown it in a sea of
stupidity we're gonna cancel it out by
having a bunch of ignoramuses vote so
that your vote no longer matters
that's why they like having high voter
turnout and that's why they're afraid of
louver toward voter turnout because when
they know that they know that when the
voter turnout is low that means that
that that it's going to predominantly be
the really invested in interested people
who voted and those are the scary ones
those the ones you don't want they want
the high voter turn and that's why
you'll even see like they're gonna
they're gonna you know organize
campaigns to have buses show up and just
you know like pick people up people that
are just laying on their couch watching
reality TV with cheeto crumbs on there
they're gonna send people in to lift
them up and carry them you could still
be in their pajamas doesn't matter just
keep staying your pajamas we will lift
you into the poll carry you so you have
to meet you
it requires no effort from you
whatsoever and we'll just bring you in
and we yeah we want those people to vote
people who otherwise would make no
effort whatsoever we want them from the
politicians perspective we want them in
the polls
because those are the ones who are
easily manipulated and those are the
people who aren't going to hold us
accountable because they have no idea
what's going on now we may say that and
and I hear this a lot that well you know
it's it's it's it's our civic duty to go
vote it's a civic duty no not exactly
or it is but with qualifiers you see
your first civic duty is to be informed
aware invested and contributing so your
first civic duty is to be an informed
aware invested contributing member of
society that is your first civic duty if
you have not completed that duty if you
have not completed step one then you
absolutely should not graduate to step
two which is voting
and it's crazy I think for us to say
that well even if you haven't done the
first thing you should definitely still
do the second thing what why your duty
is not to just vote your duty is to make
informed intelligent votes that's your
duty voting in and of itself is nothing
so all these people that I think they
put on they go vote based on nothing
they go vote based on like whose last
name they they think sounds good coolest
and then they put their I voted sticker
on and they say I voted you shouldn't be
proud of that you should be ashamed you
should be ashamed that you went and
voted based on nothing you should be
ashamed that you just cancelled out
somebody is informed vote just so you
could get a sticker it's shameful it's
embarrassing you didn't do your duty did
the opposite of your duty if you're not
informed if you're not aware of anything
if you can't point to a country on the
map if you don't know anything about our
system of government then your duty is
to stay home and not vote
and and then and then learn something
and the next time around go vote so here
I think we wanted to correct the problem
if we wanted to make some improvement if
we wanted to make drastic improvements
to to admit to our society in our system
overnight I think we could in state
three changes and I know that these
three things will never happen but I'm
gonna suggest them anyway
first two things I'll just say quickly
the first thing is I think we have to
get rid of early voting
you know when we refer to voting day in
reality it's more like voting week or
voting month because it's it's too
ambitious I guess to expect citizens to
get to the polls during a particular 12
hour span and so we want to give people
the chance to just leisure leisurely
kind of saunter in and vote whenever
they want and you know we're trying to
make it as easy as possible for everyone
I think that that that's the wrong way
of going about it we want to make it a
little more difficult we want to require
people if they're gonna vote they got to
make some sacrifices they got to really
put it in their schedule we got it we
make it a little bit harder because that
way only the people who really care are
gonna vote and those are the only ones
we want voting the ones who really care
so if but I don't maybe we still allow a
day early two days but if if if the only
way you're gonna vote is if you have
like a whole month to do it well then
you obviously don't care that much in
which case what's the point so I think
we do away with early voting I think the
second thing is is we only allow
taxpayers to vote that would be people
who are contributing only taxpayers can
vote and I would stipulate by the way
that we would include you know married
couples if if you're a married couple
then both can at least one of you is
working then you can both vote right but
the point is we want people or
contributing or chipping in
and but more importantly is we want
people who have something at stake
because taxpayers they're the ones who
are really invested and they're the ones
who can get primarily screwed if we get
bad politicians in there
it's always been recognized that it's a
bad situation when people can go to the
polls and vote themselves money
right when they Kuenn they can vote for
benefits and entitlements for themselves
without having any skin in the game
whatsoever that's a bad situation
so when people who aren't contributing
at all to the public treasury when they
get to go to the polls and decide what
happens with everyone else's money I
think that's a bad situation um and then
the third thing and this this to me is
the most important thing and if we could
only do what one of the three
suggestions that I'm making right now
and again I know we'll do none of them
but if we could only do one I would say
we should require every voter to take
and pass a very basic fifth grade civics
exam just like ten questions fifth grade
level so you don't need to be a genius
you don't need to be an expert it's not
ap level stuff we're talking about it's
just it's just do you know are you
smarter than a 5th grader basically do
you know about as much about our system
of government as we would expect a ten
year old to know
and if you don't then obviously you
shouldn't be voting right if you think
that airplanes fly on Pixy dust then you
shouldn't be in the cockpit
if youth if you don't know the the the
the right temperature four four four
four chicken if you don't know what what
what temperature chicken is supposed to
be yet before it's consumed then you
shouldn't be cooking in a commercial
kitchen or any kind of kitchen not
really
and in a similar way if you can't name
the branches of government then you
don't belong at a voting booth
I don't even think this is really a
debatable position this is just right
isn't this self-evident
if you lack even basic fundamental
knowledge about our government and about
our laws and about the current political
scene you should not be anywhere near a
polling station on voting day nothing
it's nothing personal and nothing
against you you're you're you are a
person equal in dignity and value to all
other people but your vote is not equal
in value your vote has no real actual
value because it's based on nothing
now I'm not suggesting that every voter
should have a degree in American history
or political science I'm just saying
that every voter should have a basic
grasp on
on the system that there that they are
now taking part in so I would suggest
just a simple 10 question quiz covering
some really basic questions and if you
answer let's say 7 out of 10 correctly
and you show your ID then you can vote
if you answer if you can only answer
let's say four to six questions
correctly then your voting privileges
will be suspended for let's say two or
three years to give you time to kind of
catch up and learn a few things and if
you can answer zero questions correctly
then you should be deported to Canada
sorry Canada that will be this that's
anyway if I were dictator of the country
that's the system I would have in place
maybe a more realistic goal would just
be answer seven I've done correctly and
you can vote
think of now it'll never happen but
think about the changes that would occur
to our system
if something as simple as this were
instated
every person voting just had a
fifth-graders understanding of our of
our system and of the world think about
the changes and all of the changes would
be for the better I can't think of one
single negative change that would happen
because of this
there'd be a lot of negative changes for
bad politicians who are now being held
accountable and of course that's the
reason why this will never happen
because it would require politicians to
come up with this idea and in state at
which they will never ever do so we're
kind of stuck with the system as it is
but I
it's helpful to have this conversation
because it helps us understand you know
how voting is supposed to work
and and and what the point of voting
actually is and so that even if even if
there's never a system put in place to
weed out the ignorant people maybe at
least we can encourage people who know
that they are ignorant can encourage
them that when voting day comes around
just stay home until you have cured
yourself of your ignorance and then you
could partake in this wonderful thing
called voting
that's my suggestion thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed